[Music]
hundreds of employees within nevada's
higher education system will be without
a job as of tomorrow big decision on
vaccines was made in a special board of
regents meeting more than a week after
state lawmakers struck down a mandate
for students victoria saha has been
monitoring this closely joining us live
with what exactly went into this
decision
ryan there were many supporters on both
sides of this heated topic but
ultimately the board of regents
directors decided to do what was best to
keep everyone safe
the motion fails
in a six to six vote the board of
regents for nevada system of higher
education decided to keep vaccine
mandate for employees as is this special
meeting was held just one day before
more than 300 employees would be without
a job because they didn't get a covid
vaccine public comment poured in from
all across nevada if the vaccine works
they have nothing to fear from those who
are unvaxed doug unger is a professor
with unlv he came prepared to show the
thousands of signatures he gathered to
support the employee vaccine mandate we
do not want to have to work in an unsafe
campus with unvaccinated employees back
and forth between the board of regents
continued if you uh support taking the
vaccination
the vax
then why worry about getting covered
from anyone else after the current
mandate was voted to stay in place there
was a motion to extend the termination
deadline to january 15 but that did not
pass
employees who are without a job tomorrow
have until january 31st to get their job
back only if they provide proof of
vaccination victoria saha live local now